a massive swimming pool and a new record
aren't the only things that made the
training for Avatar the way of warzer so
fascinating and grueling let's dive in
audiences have been ready for another
adventure on Pandora for over a decade
and director James Cameron is more than
happy to oblige the way of water is
finally here 13 years after the original
Avatar became the highest grossing film
in history the three-hour epic sees Jake
Sully and natiri's new family fight back
against dangers from the past with the
help of some new allies bringing Avatar
2 to theaters became a Monumental effort
for Cameron years of writing and delays
pushed filming on the sequel to 2017. at
that time the notable filmmaker put
together some of the industry's most
cutting-edge techniques and visual
effects to bring his vision to life he
also introduced some unique production
aspects that would push the Avatar cast
to their limits one of the most
demanding challenges for the cast came
in the form of a giant tank that could
hold over 250 000 gallons of water
measuring over 30 feet deep this
enormous set provided the perfect
environment for aquatic motion capture
suits the tank gave Cameron the ability
to control every detail something he
couldn't do in an ocean setting the way
of water shoots went beyond the scale of
any previous project and required the
cast to be prepared for anything lead
actor Sam Worthington decided on an
intensive trading regimen he spent a
year with Navy Seals which helped him
develop abilities crucial to spending
long periods underwater despite the
stressful environment the actor found a
helpful way to stay calm Worthington
told extra my trick was to forget how
deep I was forget that I was running out
of air and just do my job let's get it
done cast members would have to be in
the water for upwards of 15 or 16 hours
but they were not alone they were joined
by teams that specialized in free diving
safety in addition to all the camera
Crews it may have seemed dangerous for
Worthington but Cameron was committed to
everyone's welfare the actor said to
Empire Cameron is never going to put us
in trouble he's done enough missions
that he understands that this was kind
of a mission-based approach to
filmmaking co-star Kate Winslet also
found herself diving into potential
danger in her new role as ronal of the
Met kaina she pushed the limits of
breath holding during Film Production
spending over seven minutes underwater
and breaking a record previously held by
Tom Cruise Worthington Winslet and the
other Navi actors had to overcome some
surprising challenges in the way of
water showing some serious Devotion to
their characters and the process doing
extended takes underwater meant that
cast had to balance the demands of a
screenworthy performance with the all
too real fears of drowning Worthington
said it was a particularly scary
experience while speaking to reporters
during the film's international press
tour some of the more notable moments at
the way of water include scenes that
focus on Jake's Sully's relationship
with his sons Worthington described the
lack of communication between Jake
netayum and lo Arc as Heartbreaker king
and the addition of an element of danger
only raised to stakes in each emotional
moment Worthington told GQ it's hard
enough to do on land and we put it under
water where your oxygen is depleting and
it's kind of risky but that's what Jim
Cameron's good at for Cameron staging an
underwater scene is like staging a dance
it's almost like choreography or
figuring out the choreography but
Worthington though Cameron's approach is
geared toward two groups audiences and
creatives the former has benefited from
Decades of Cameron Creations ranging
from Titanic to Terminator to Judgment
Day now Avatar the way of water is
pushing new boundaries and on-screen
technology to make the most of it the
filmmaker used these extreme methods to
create visuals that are winning rave
reviews and quite possibly more box
office records
[Music]